bientôt aux discussions se trouve sur
izia teinture sur l'ipad souvenez vous
n'avez fait normal adventure et strange
adventures
on peut pas se passer de cette voiture
ça m'avait manqué tout ça thebluepill ce
poison nous d'accord kaka était un point
donné mais c'est bien ça commence
extrêmement bien à les gars calmez vous
quoi les semoirs espérer de seconde
ok je sors la solution bras alors le
vieux classique alors voila tu es là en
ligne
oh le coup du sort
ah ça fait longtemps ça me fait plaisir
moi et fort modérément plaisir à les
[ __ ] c'est drôle sahara et on passe de
l'autre côté au elle vu les réflexes à
trois vaches faut pas aller en bas ben
on va pas en bas il succède 10 c'est la
baisse bes toile à la pub à la voile en
faisant ça
auger la papeterie ok ce n'est qu'à
quelqu'un sur la tête
et bien qu'il ait pu rater c'est dur à
dire cette phrase comment se passe ta
journée est-ce que c'est beaucoup plus
facile cette fois
ouais ça va j'ai fait de mon mieux pour
ce jeu soit facile les gens avec un qi
de plus de 250 dont aucun problème
bon bah ça va alors wade font ces
bâtards yark la cambuse 4 s'appelle ça
bien là il s'enfuit hockey niveaux
suivants dont j'ai passé rapidement sans
aucun problème à eau au fdp
j'ai la solution non et non allez way
aux as hb état mais c'est toujours le
même tricks qui reviendront connais bien
les tricks wow c'est bon et là on n'est
pas dans les nuages qui piquent taille à
la totale se monte bla bla bla je te
baise au hockey on est prêts à activer
la manivelle
désolé bros au hockey
attention à ta peine jean michel esquive
jean-michel esquive alloc
adobe est saisie en fait juste à revenir
voilà j'y viens pardon tu as totalement
une blague quoi
adecco enfin ol était revenu font juste
repasser sur le levier
voilà c'est pas mal ça j'ai bien aimé ah
bah on peut au juge gratuitement en jeu
vidéo voilà coup d'épée tumeur ou quoi
il fait semblant
il feint la mort comme les chasseurs
dans mot la bonne taille de guy môquet
faut juste par le bouton attention c'est
parti à temps mais comment fennecs la
douille sa bosse et le ce1 possible ces
faits kessé feh kessé un des atouts plus
vite pas parler d'eux avec est jamais
allé je pourrais retourner au perso j'en
étais sûr qu avait un texte comme ça de
merde je me casse batta le choc
aujourd'hui d'un tricheur non je suis
juste et règles à temps mais laisse moi
le temps de comprendre le duke quoi mais
c'est impossible je sais ce que nous
devons et dans le tunnel abreu voilà au
bac et au vol au le pédo plat non je
suis et je sais qu'on lui échappe et
bien là vient la paix des eaux vient là
là là c'est easy un cactus my way se met
la voilà à laetitia faisait si longtemps
qu'ils changent de place mais ça c'est
juste pas juste quoi c'est pas drôle ça
fait rire personne dans le monde de
l'audiovisuel dans le monde du jeu vidéo
et dans mon de la pâte ici aussi
personne rigole bonjour monsieur kaka
bra astuces n'appuie pas sur le cube
ok ok bonne astuce nous prend le flingue
on va tuer les gens on prend le plein
guerre on va tuer des gens qui n'osent
ont tué à bec à ces mois passés à la fin
ouais il va rencontrer sa madame non si
elle je la tue juste en dessous lui la
habana voilà il se trouvait voilà l'idée
de merde alors on est bien on est bien
on est bien on est bien panique pas et
audio panique a un peu cassé
oh oh c'est chaud mon gars oui mais il
faut couper un truc pour le cas ces mecs
ont ils rouspètent beaucoup lucas
hochart aujourd'hui un an les grincheux
un à un [ __ ] de manille qui est avec
le quai le plus fébrile de france à bla
bla oh mais voilà il se prendre la tête
pour rien
salut je suis un alpaca est ce que tu es
un alpaga tôt et si non quelles soient
bâtard n'en ont pas ce jeu si on passe
voilà au pad j'avais trouvé j'en ai
marre ok province 10 juin 10 l'arrêt ça
me saoule à propos des questions pour
les astuces qui est le mec le plus
brillant et plus beau ses développeurs
ce développeur ce développeur à vous
jeter son arme watts
c'est n'importe quoi un bouton qui ont
caché un doute on n'a jamais vu ça enfin
si on avait sa chance au visage mais n'a
jamais vu un mec aussi fort que toi je
sais allez dégage
allons voyons chaque cas ça devient vite
insupportable au wat
ah je sais pas si on va là bas voilà à
nagano
quant à elle à tout prix les
développeurs et les futés un aller fut
je veux dire dans vos bijoux voleurs au
la bonne blague
là on est pour l'indépendant des
bonhommes ont les [ __ ] aller il
suffit de faire ça on peut y aller
ouais ça c'était prévisible heureusement
qu au ça c'est un peu moi wall e là
monsieur kaka si un coup d'épée [ __ ]
si jamais la fin assez dur
hop
allez allez
abu dhabi il faut juste pas casser cette
brique la regarder voilà c'est ça c'est
ça comme ça là et hop il retourne
jusqu'au bout ok j'ai compris le truc
vos missions au
lord oakeshott un tout petit bâtard je
battrai eux tous les jours
en fait juste un mec voilà voilà jean
michel qu'on allait bientôt à plus 1,2 à
plus de 3,1 +34 un + 4/5 ça vient de
changer mike 5
j'en peux plus qui est le mec plus
incroyables note mais non toujours toi
joue au foot pour avoir la réponse quoi
mais c'est quoi ce jeu marée vert devait
de pleurer mais non attends mais là je
suis pété un câble à base et là ça
coince à me casser les spectres
[Musique]
d'habitude c'est pas sérieux quand on a
fait la moitié du tour dans la moitié du
temps aux alors c'est quoi
faux le produit mais j'ai tapoter
partout tout ça pas marché voilà fait
mettre dedans et phase 1 non mais c'est
abuser ça c'est quoi se dit voilà je
défends 2,2 pour bourges est vaste et
plus et 15 des peines et les vidéos que
d'habitude bon j'avoue aujourd'hui
j'aurais dû jouer à autre chose qu'un
jour à jour voilà j'aurai du jeu par
exemple un simulateur de sommeil on
s'adresse à une prochaine vidéo portée
portez vous bien que j'ai tellement pis
[Musique]